faut savoir que l'album du finaliste a
été déjà programmé les chansons sont
prêtes la production a déjà tout fait et
ce qui est assez exceptionnel c'est que
nous avons trois artistes de renom qui
ont préparé cet album à savoir vite à
Slimane et Vianney c'est pas rien on
adore
ça veut dire que du coup forcément cet
album il ressemblera pas forcément la
personnalité du gagnant parce que déjà
fait ah bah oui
le but c'est quand même de sortir
l'album des gens viennent donc on va
aller très très vite je sais pas si vous
souvenez ils ont fait venir Lara Fabian
pendant pendant l'émission et en fait
ils l'ont elle a fait une Master Class
en fait c'est une façon pour eux de
tester de tester en fait Lara Fabian ce
qu'ils aimerait bien que l'année
prochaine elle intègre le corps
professoral de l'émission
Star Academy et The Voice alterne voilà
et du coup elle sera libre une année et